[Music]
my name is Doug Melton and I'm the
Thomas Dudley Cabot professor of the
Natural Sciences at Harvard University
and the co-director of the Harvard Stem
Cell Institute
I'm delighted today to talk to you about
a new era in medicine based in
regenerative biology it has to do with
the subject of how our bodies are made
how they're maintained or replenished
and it's going to change your life it's
going to lead to longer and healthier
lives for humans in a way that was
really unimaginable just a few decades
ago to put this in perspective let's
think back to about a century ago where
infectious disease was very common and
many humans would suffer and die from
what we would now call a normal
bacterial infection whooping cough
diphtheria other kinds of diseases like
polio could cause and did cause enormous
human suffering because we didn't
understand the basics of infectious
disease with the discovery of bacterial
infections and most importantly with the
discovery of penicillin a sort of
miracle occurred where it was then
possible to cure people that had
bacterial infections we're now at the
edge of a similar revolution of biology
it's a biology based in stem cells and
genetics and it has to do with
understanding how our bodies are made
are made maintained and replenished and
it will also teach us something deeply
important about disease most
interestingly perhaps it also will open
the door to manipulating our bodies in a
way that we can change who we are and
what our lives are like to put this in a
little more perspective let me remind
you that in the last century beginning
with Mendel's discoveries of peas and
genetic inheritance we learned about how
the genes we inherit from our mother and
father affect who we are that was
reduced to understanding that genes are
made of DNA the chemical stuff of
genes is DNA and we now understand quite
a bit about how genes encode the
proteins that are found in our body it
however can be an exaggeration often
appearing in the popular press that all
we are is our DNA and we're much more
than our DNA our DNA is merely a
language or a code that tells our body
or ourselves what kind of proteins can
be made but the DNA doesn't define who
we are so what has been lost in this
discussion up till now is the idea that
the real unit of biology is not DNA but
is instead of cell cells are alive cells
make more cells and cells are the units
that allow us to harness the future of
our bodies and regenerative medicine in
order to make sense of this we have to
dig into a little bit of a kind of
biology called developmental biology
that's the biology as shown here that
has to do with answering the question
how does an egg become a human being how
does it make make a human body
I'm going to show you some pictures of
how this happens and talk a bit about
the very early stages of human life in
this picture here you see the first
spark that starts human development that
is fertilization you see a large yellow
egg there a human egg with many sperm
trying to fertilize it only one sperm
wins one of those blue headed sperm and
that then leads to the first step which
will be cell division cell division
occurs rapidly over the first few days
of development and as you see in this
picture there are two cells that have
formed from the fertilized egg
development proceeds a pace and forms an
early stage of development called a
blastocyst the portion of this picture
in the upper left is called the inner
cell mass and the few cells they are out
of the 100 cells at the blastocyst stage
it's those few cells in the upper left
that will give rise to the human body
within a few hours development proceeds
quite quickly and we can see here by one
month later the basic body form is
already apparent one can see the
beginning of arms and legs the heart the
eye and the facial cavities are starting
to form it's just a short time after
that at 46 days when it's obvious then
that an embryo is already formed there's
an arm and a lake and you can see a kind
of cavity at the top in this picture
where the brain hasn't fully formed
brain cells are being made but they're
not completely developed yet
then by 70 days you see something that's
clearly human not yet fully developed
but clearly human for me this is really
one of the most mysterious and wondrous
things about biology how does that
fertilized they make this human in just
seventy days now it's not a human being
yet but it's clearly on its way to being
a human and I like to sort of contrast
this with things that were commonly
amazed by in our life things like an
iPod or a computer are not nearly as
wondrous to me is how this fertilized
they made all of these body parts in
just 70 days well to look at that in a
bit more detail
there are two aspects to human
development the first is obvious is
growth cells not only divide but they
have to increase in size and that growth
occurs inside the womb of the mother but
the second and the one we'll focus on
today is a process called
differentiation where cells become
different from one another here you see
different cells of the early embryo will
give rise to different kinds of cells in
the adult the blue cells are
representing nerve the red cells there
in the middle are blood cells and at the
bottom is an organ the pancreas which
makes insulin so that we can make use of
our food their process of
differentiation proceeds until we make
all of the different kinds of cells in
the human body it's estimated that there
are about 350 different kinds of cells
in the human body and as you see then
the puzzle is how do these cells arise
from a single fertilized egg in the last
century we've learned quite a bit about
that the first thing we know is that
there are approximately 25,000 human
genes bits of DNA that code for proteins
that make up all the proteins found in
ourselves now the puzzle then for a
developmental biologist is to figure out
how do those 25,000 genes get mixed and
matched to make all the different kinds
of cells we don't understand that in
detail yet but that's an exciting and an
important problem for the next
generation of biologists how do you take
25,000 genes and make all the different
cells in the body I sometimes think an
interesting analogy for that is when you
go to a Chinese restaurant you can often
see hundreds of dishes on the menu but
if you're in the kitchen you might only
find 10 or 12 different pots it's the
way things are mixed and matched that
make the different meals similarly it's
the way our gene expression is mixed and
matched at different times and amounts
that makes all the different kinds of
cells in our body now an important point
is discover just in the last few decades
is that while cells become different
they retain the capacity to do
everything else this is quite an amazing
potential
and it was demonstrated or identified by
an important experiment called cloning
many of you will have heard about
cloning and I'm going to explain that to
you in a bit of detail now because it
establishes a very important principle
that all of the cells in our body have
this enormous potential locked inside of
them this next picture then shows the
result of the first cloned animal you
see 30 cloned adult frogs these are
genetically identical it's as if they're
twins many times over they were prepared
from a mating of the two albino or white
frog those two a male and a female frog
were mated to make an albino frog and
then nuclei were taken from that and
injected into the egg of the donor
that's a wild-type or a normal frog and
that then gave rise as I've said to this
cloned animal 30 times over one could do
this again and again and make many
animals by this cloning procedure let's
have a look in a little more detail with
a cartoon of how that's actually done
because it's an important experiment
showing how one can reveal the potential
of all of the genes in our cells in this
little cartoon movie you'll see a
pipette come and remove the nucleus that
contains all of the genes from this the
egg cell so here comes the pipette
removing the nucleus leaving just the
cytoplasm of the cell the picture now
shows taking the nucleus from a skin
cell and injecting that into the egg
cell that sparks development it goes on
to proceed as shown in this cartoon
where the nucleus is now receiving
signals from the cytoplasm as to which
genes should be turned on and off and
development will proceed by cell
division it'll then give rise to the
blastocyst stage that I mentioned
earlier and you see in this picture the
blue cells appear shortly those are the
cells of the inner cell mass that will
give rise to the whole embryo so that's
the cells the blue cells there at the
top I thought it would be nice to see
what does this look like in real life so
now I have a real-life movie of a
cloning experiment we
done with mice here you see on the left
a holding pipette which just provides a
little suction to hold on to the egg the
egg is inside and the injection pipette
on the right has to penetrate a membrane
that egg has got this protective
membrane and the pipette is drilling a
little hole in there it's now drilled
the hole and has removed the nucleus
from the egg you can see the nucleus is
that sausage shaped thing inside the
pipette which is going to be spit out so
now we have a cytoplasm which is the
recipient for the cloning experiment
we'll get that one out of the way and
now I'll show in the next part of this
picture a new way coming in which has
been enucleated and now we're going to
inject a nucleus from a skin cell into
that egg the pipettes going to be pushed
deep into the cytoplasm and squirt the
nucleus into that egg and you can do
tens of these at once and then
re-implant the injected egg into a mouse
to give rise to the cloned animal now it
looks relatively easy here it's not
something you could do at home but with
practice you can become quite an expert
at this cloning procedure as a result of
that at least one famous clone has been
made that's the famous sheep dolly after
that finding it's been possible to clone
a number of kinds of animals sheep cows
mice goats pigs rabbits horses ferrets I
note also common pets cats and dogs
what's missing from this list is humans
well let me be clear as far as I know no
one has ever cloned the human in fact
I'm reasonably confident that hasn't
been done because it's not a trivial
thing to do nevertheless there is the
question of should it be done at all
well scientists like myself have no
interest in cloning humans because we've
already learned the biological principle
principles we need and want to know from
cloning but it does raise an interesting
ethical question or a moral question
should one clone humans some arguments
against this have been that it would be
wrong to make genetically identical
individuals well that's sort of a silly
argument because identical twins are
genetically identical
it really has to do more with whether or
not we have a right to control the genes
and the phenotype of a human by creating
an identical copy and I think that's
immoral not a biological question
for a biologist however cloning humans
is not the interesting challenge what we
can conclude from cloning is the
following the nucleus of the cells in
your body many if not all of the
differentiated cells in your body can be
reprogrammed by egg cytoplasm so that
they can become fully potent stem cells
and make an entire new animal another
way of saying that is that during
development from a fertilized egg to an
adult human there are no irreversible
changes to the genes altogether called
our genome during development what I'd
like you to remember from this is that
many cells in your body have this
astounding potential they have locked in
their nucleus the capacity to make any
other part of your body regenerative
medicine is all about harnessing that
potential to make new cells and to treat
and cure diseases if one's in an
accident and loses some tissue or an
organ or as is more common suffering
from a disease a liver disease or heart
disease or disease of the skin one could
and should be able to use our body's own
inherent capacity for development to
replace or repair those lost tissues one
could and should be able to use our
body's own inherent capacity for
development to replace or repair those
lost tissues
now our bodies as you may know have the
capacity to do some replenishment on
their own
not all parts of our body but some of
them are constantly replenished you
probably know your skin turns over and
is constantly renewed when you got up
this morning and looked in the mirror
you of course recognized yourself but if
you were looking at the level of
individual skin cells on your face
you're looking at a completely new
person a person that wasn't there three
months ago and that's because our skin
is slough tauf and new skin cells come
back again and again that's also true
for our intestine that is our gut our
gut cells are slough off at a very rapid
rate and are constantly being repaired
and replaced so our body has the
capacity to renew and replenish some of
our tissues but clearly we don't have an
obvious capacity for major organ
replacement if you were to lose part of
your brain or to lose a limb your body
doesn't have the capacity to replenish
or replace that and yet I've told you
that our cells have all that information
inside we want to therefore understand
really this process of regeneration why
is it that the liver can regenerate and
other tissues don't
now as I've indicated and as you know we
as humans aren't very good at
regeneration but there is one vertebrate
one animal with a backbone which is
extremely good at regeneration it's what
I would call the king of regeneration an
expert and he's our salamanders common
salamanders found in ponds all across
the United States these animals can do
an enormous feat of regeneration they
can regenerate their tail they can
regenerate their limbs their lower jaw
and some of their internal organs and I
thought I'd show you a movie here a
cartoon of what we know about this and
how it works so in this picture here
you're going to see a cartoon of the
normal process of regeneration sped up
by time-lapse photography so here a limb
had been amputated and you see taking
pictures every few days a new limb
growing back now a cartoon of what this
looks like is shown here and if you're a
little queasy you can avert your eyes
when a little scissor comes into this
cartoon what we're going to do is cut
off the limb here comes our scissors to
remove it that leads to a little bit of
bleeding the bleeding stops that's the
worst part and now a special skin called
the wound epidermis grows over the stump
and now inside a quite amazing process
takes place you can see here the bone
and white and the muscle in red is
starting to be changed to D
differentiate to become unspecialized
and create a mound of cells they will
then go on to grow and recapitulate or
reproduce the normal process of
development that takes a couple months
time new cartilage and bone forms
there's a new radius and ulna and all
the carpals and the digits of the hand
so now our happy little salamander has
his limb back and he's ready to go back
and swim in the pond and realize the
time-lapse pictures shown here in still
forms show that if one cuts through the
upper arm through the radius and ulna or
cuts here through the humerus one can
see that in both cases by 70 days the
animal has regenerated its entire limbs
the point I'd like to make here is that
vertebrate animals have in their cells
the capacity to make any new part of the
body and salamanders have figured out
how to do this at large scale a great
challenge for us now is to figure out
how we could learn to harness those
processes to use them in human biology
[Music]
[Applause]
I've already mentioned that cells in
your body are not static that they turn
over our intestinal cells last a few
days
blood cells last up to about 10 weeks
and you sort of already know that
because you may have donated blood at a
blood drive when you go to a blood drive
you are not permanently and deficit for
the blood you donate it but your body
tops up and makes new blood the pancreas
cells on the other hand cells that are
important for digestion and the use of
food live for months and your brain
cells are nearly permanent they don't
really turn over at any appreciable rate
there are two ways this is done one way
is for a fully specialized differentiate
itself to just divide and make two that
happens for cells in our pancreas and in
the kidney for example but for many
tissues in our body there's a special
cell called a stem cell that cell has
two interesting properties one is it can
make more of itself and the second
important one is that some of the
daughter cells can become specialized
and do different things a stem cell then
has these two essential properties
self-renewal and the capacity to make
specialized cells
I'm gonna focus a bit on this first one
of self-renewal I've been talking about
how we renew our bodies
well the stem cell does that on its own
that is one cell can make more of itself
if we can understand how a stem cell
makes more of itself that should deeply
inform our thinking about how we could
renew not only a cell but tissues and
organs so we're very keen to understand
this process of self renewal the second
thing a stem cell can do is to make
specialized the differentiated cells
probably the best-known of these is a
bone marrow stem cell a blood stem cell
which has given the cancer victims and
this cell makes all of the tissues of
the blood now among stem cells there's
my favorite one the one that has truly
special abilities and that's called an
embryonic stem cell an embryonic stem
cell can not only self renew like all
other stem cells but it's special
capacity is to make all different kinds
of cells indeed it can make blood it can
make nerve it can make the whole
pancreatic islet the part of the
pancreas that makes the hormone insulin
so if one thinks about the significance
of that
that means the discovery in the last
couple of decades of stem cells has
provided us with a reagent a tool that
can make any tissue in the body it can
make all of the skin brain and nerve
what's called the ectoderm of a body the
outside of our body it can make all of
the tissues on the inside the mesoderm
which includes blood heart kidney muscle
and bone and it can make the gut tube
the endoderm the lung the liver the
stomach the pancreas the intestine so to
emphasize this I want to show you a
movie something we do with students in
the lab where we take human embryonic
stem cells that are growing in a dish
and turn them into beating heart cells
here we have human embryonic stem cells
growing in a petri dish as colonies if
we remove the conditions that allow them
to self renew they will begin to
automatically specialize and you can see
here it's demonstrated or indicated by
red
yellow blue and purple cells but I want
to highlight one particular kind of cell
that can form here which is human heart
cells so the movie shows these cells
beating there's a little tiny clump of
cells beating just like a heart here are
four different examples of it might
remind you of Edgar Allan Poe store the
tell-tale heart where he couldn't stop
the heart from beating under the
floorboards here once we take these
human ES cells as we call them and a
dish making heart cells they'll beat
forever and ever
now the trouble here is that we're not
making a heart I want to emphasize that
we're making a tiny little clump of
cells and so biologists have been
thinking about how could we use those
beating human heart cells to actually
make a real heart well this picture
shows the way we might go about doing
that in this case we're taking a rodent
the rat heart and removing all of the
cells leaving a kind of ghost you see
here the white ghost on the right which
is a D cellular eyes drat heart so it
just has the matrix the kind of
scaffolding for a heart but there aren't
any beating cells there and it's dead
tissue we concede that that scaffold
with human or mouse embryonic stem cells
that have been turned into heart
progenitors and they will go on then to
form a beating heart here you see this
heart pumping away which has heart cells
that are made from embryonic stem cells
that's the sort of beginning of a field
called bioengineering where we're
thinking about how we would make organs
and then eventually of course Transplant
them into people
now one thing I've skipped over here is
where are these special these especially
interesting important embryonic stem
cells come from where do we get human
embryonic stem cells those are derived
from a sort of complicated procedure
making use of material from in vitro
fertilization clinics so as you probably
know some couples who want to have a
baby are unable to do so by what we
would call natural means they go to
their doctor at the IVF clinic in vitro
fertilization clinic and donate an egg
in a sperm which is then fertilized in
vitro if that's successful some of those
fertilize the eggs are re implanted into
a woman and then after nine months a
baby is born no matter what happens at
the end of that procedure if there is a
baby and it's successful or if not there
are almost always leftover human
fertilized eggs
it's estimated that they're about four
hundred thousand such eggs in freezers
in the United States my colleagues and I
use those to derive human embryonic stem
cells we derive them with fully informed
consent where the sperm and the egg
donor have said rather than throw that
material away why not use it to try to
find out more about human development
and disease so what you see is that we
can take a human fertilized egg allow it
to develop to the blastocyst stage which
I'd mentioned before in a petri dish and
then from the inside of that culture out
and derive human embryonic stem cells
the inner cell mass of these cultured
blastocyst is removed and put in a petri
dish and then after some weeks of
growing we can isolate human embryonic
stem cell colonies from it a real-life
picture of that shows a blastocyst with
its inner cell mass on the left and then
the colonies of human embryonic stem
cells derived on the right and over the
last decade we've gotten quite good at
this and now we can isolate human
embryonic stem cells with about a 50%
efficiency it is worth noting that this
has raised ethical questions which have
important political implications and
something for further discussion
nonetheless I believe that it's
perfectly justified in fact it's
something we should certainly do
try to alleviate human suffering by
making use of this material which would
otherwise be thrown away to try to find
treatments and cures for human disease
I'm glad to say that in recent years
there's been another possibility of
creating a human stem cell what we call
a pluripotent stem cell which has many
but not exactly all of the properties of
the human embryonic stem cell and this
one doesn't have the ethical
complications of beginning with a human
fertilized egg this method is to take a
portion of skin a skin biopsy and then
to add DNA or RNA genes that encode
reprogramming factors to these skin
cells and we can make a patient specific
stem cell shown here in multiple colors
because of a fluorescent image which is
very similar they're not exactly
identical to a human embryonic stem cell
in the next few years we may be able to
find ways of turning these into a fully
potent cell just like a human embryonic
stem cell and that would be wonderful
because it would then remove the need
for dealing with these human fertilized
eggs what do we do with these stem cells
as I've said there are two kinds of
things we want to think about using them
for one is to make tissues and organs as
I've already described with the human
heart but let's talk about how we could
use them to replace tissues in the
disease state and/or use them as tools
to discover new drugs so now I want to
talk about why scientists are so excited
about embryonic stem cells and stem
cells in general and how we plan to use
them
I haven't talked much about the
generative diseases so let me explain
what I mean by them the generative
diseases are diseases where a particular
cell type in the body becomes
dysfunctional or is destroyed in the
case of neurodegeneration that would be
in the forebrain basal neurons and the
forebrain are lost in the disease known
as Alzheimer's in Parkinson's disease
it's a different neuron at the neuron in
the midbrain that makes a chemical
signal called dopamine another kind of
neurodegenerative disease is sometimes
called Lou Gehrig's disease or a Maya
tropic lateral sclerosis it's a real
mouthful and we usually abbreviate it as
ALS that's a disease where the nerves
that innervate your muscles are
degenerated and you can no longer move
you can't breathe and you unfortunately
die from that there's no treatment for
it another disease of the generation
would be cardiovascular disease a
disease of the heart tissue or the blood
vessels which degenerate over time
leading to heart attacks and possibly
death the disease I work on diabetes is
one where our body's metabolism can't
function anymore often because a cell in
the pancreas that makes insulin is lost
and therefore there's no insulin and we
can't make use of the food wheat what
all of these degenerative diseases have
in common is that they have a genetic
makeup that inclines the patient to get
the disease but doesn't guarantee that
they will get it there's another factor
an environmental factor which you could
say pushes a person over the edge and
causes them to get the disease a good
example would be of an environmental
factor would be the Sun for skin cancer
or smoking for lung cancer a person may
be inclined to get one of those diseases
one of those cancers but it's the
environmental factor that pushes it over
the edge might be worth pointing out
that all of these degenerative diseases
like diabetes have an enormous social
and health consequence on the individual
but also a really enormous economic
consequence on our society it's
estimated for example by the US
government that the cost of treating
diabetes in America runs on the order of
about a hundred and seventy billion not
million billion dollars per year so
these are very important
social and health problems that we would
like to address I'd like to talk then
about how we can treat these diseases
with stem cells by focusing on the fact
that in each of these cases a single
kind of cell is lost in the case of
diabetes the cell which is lost is a
cell in the pancreas called the beta
cell which makes insulin there dhoop
types of diabetes there's adult onset
usually related to obesity where people
don't initially use their insulin
producing cells but about 10% of that
population eventually loses them and
becomes insulin dependent the type of
diabetes that I work on is called
juvenile or type 1 diabetes which is an
autoimmune disease where the body's own
immune system wrongly identifies its own
cells its own pancreatic beta cells and
kills them off leaving the patient
without the ability to make insulin and
therefore requiring regular insulin
injections well if the cells in the
pancreas are lost there would look
something like this
the blue cells here are cells that have
been stained with an antibody for
insulin so they're the cells in your
body that make the hormone insulin every
human has about 800,000 to a million of
these little spheres these islets which
contain the insulin producing cells
within them in a type 1 diabetic as I've
said the body attacks those blue cells
and eliminates them in this picture here
you see that the blue cells are gone
there are no insulin producing cells and
the patient is now entirely dependent on
daily blood glucose checks and the
insulin injections the way this can be
treated now which doesn't work for large
numbers of people but has been
demonstrated to work is that human
islets can be isolated from cadavers it
usually takes two cadavers to prepare
enough islets those shown here in red
are the insulin producing cells and they
can be transplanted into a diabetic and
that can make that person independent of
insulin injections for many years what
we'd like to do then is to make islet
cells that is the pancreatic insulin
producing beta cells
from human embryonic stem cells the way
we go about doing that is to first
understand how beta cells are normally
made and then we try to recapitulate a
reproduce that using human embryonic
stem cells we then first have to
instruct it to tell it to become part of
the gut to the endodermal it needs other
instructions to tell it to become part
of the pancreas within the pancreas it
has to become endocrine a hormone
producing cell and then finally we have
to reach our target of the human beta
cell we're not there yet but I'm
confident that we're going to be able to
make bucketloads of these beta cells in
the next few years and as I've indicated
before this is just one application for
human embryonic stem cells if we go back
to look at the list of these
degenerative diseases many investigators
are working on how to make midbrain
neurons to treat Parkinson's patients
motor neurons for ALS cardiac muscle
cells I've already shown and I just
mentioned pancreatic beta cells for type
1 diabetes so one big grand goal of the
use of human embryonic stem cells is to
make cells which are deficient in
disease and use those for
transplantation in the next few years I
predict we'll be able to see major
advances in that for treatment of
diabetes in some nurtured neuro
degenerative diseases there is however
another completely independent or
parallel path where stem cells are used
not as products to put into people but
are used as tools for drug discovery
so drugs of course are small molecules
or chemicals that you take to change
your body's phenotype your body's
activity I'd like to describe an example
where quite a lot of progress has been
made in studying one of the
neurodegenerative diseases one in which
motor neurons are lost the idea for this
experiment is to take embryonic stem
cells from a patient that suffers from
Lou Gehrig's disease ALS or a similar
disease called spinal muscular atrophy
in both cases where motor neurons are
lost turn those cells into motor neurons
and then have a control or a similar
cell from a patient that doesn't have
the disease from a volunteer what we
call control embryonic stem cells the
idea here then is to use those cells in
Petri dishes and then in plates kind of
like bingo cards where all of the cells
are spread out and screened for
chemicals or potential drugs that slow
the degeneration that stop the
progression of this disease the
important point to see here is that if
we use the control cells the rate at
which they die in a petri dish goes from
the blue bars on the left to the right
where you see the slowly dying in the
case where we use cells from a patient
the cells die much more quickly the red
bars show that these motor neurons die
very quickly in a petri dish this allows
us to set up an assay to look for a drug
that will slow the progress of the
disease and tantalizingly we've already
found some examples where this can work
the green shows the amount of a protein
that is important for motor neuron life
or survival and the minus sign the drug
has not been added and the plus sign it
has and you can see much more green and
red protein when we add the drug so what
does this mean this means looking ahead
that it may be possible in the next few
years to find drugs not that cure motor
neuron disease or that reverse the loss
that's already happened but instead to
simply slow the progress of the disease
well you might say that's not such a
high bar you just want to slow the
progress but let me remind you that if
you are unfortunate enough to
be diagnosed with a disease like ALS
generally speaking people don't survive
more than three to six years so if we
found the drug which slowed down that
degenerative process we may be able to
add significant amounts of time to their
life we could double that from three to
six to maybe six to twelve more years
which would really be significant it is
in the end however not fun to be
thinking about all of these degenerative
diseases that we or our loved ones are
going to suffer from and so I'd like to
end by talking about another aspect of
that stem cell biology which has nothing
to do with disease but instead has to do
with the natural progress of aging and
how we might use themselves to mediate
against that a gene is so obvious I
hardly need to explain what it is we all
know that we age and we sense it and
feel it in our own bodies here's a nice
picture looking at an young woman who
ages and you see that over time her body
changes it's the same person cells have
been replaced but her body's capacity
for replenishment has declined over a
period of some decades so what do we
really know about aging well the
characteristics are sort of obvious one
is as a young person your organs are
quite robust your wounds heal very
rapidly and there's a high tissue
turnover rate as one ages the ability to
do all of those things declines in an
older person the organs are more frail
wounds heal very slowly and there's a
location tissue turnover rate so we
believe that by looking at the biology
of stem cells we can change the rate of
that process not reverse it nor can we
make it stop but we can slow it down so
that one would enjoy a life with let's
call it a younger healthier body I'm
going to show you one experiment which
has given us confidence that this can
happen this involves putting two mice
together what we call para biotic mice
and it's a kind of experiment I call a
Fountain of Youth experiment what we do
in this experiment is remove the outer
skin of
two mice and sew them together kind of
like Siamese twins
so we now will have a young Mouse and an
old mouse sewn together and the
consequence of that is that they share
their bloodstream they're really quite
happy they continue to live a long life
and run around in the cage and eat and
play as they normally would the
experiment I'm going to show you has to
do with injuring the muscle in the mice
and then asking whether there's anything
special about being young which allows
your body to repair better in fact I'll
remind you that when you were a little
boy or girl it was commonplace for you
to say fall off your bike or have an
accident and then not even remember it a
few days later your body was as ever as
I've already said very good at tissue
repair and healing as you aged that
ability to repair muscle and he'll fix
your bruises as it were slows down so
when I fall off my bike now I not only
remember it the next day I remember it
for several weeks it takes my body much
longer time to repair itself so this
experiment is designed to get it what is
it about a young person that allows them
to repair their muscle at a fast rate in
this experiment the paired mice have one
muscle injured a thigh muscle what you
might call a charley horse is given to
the thigh muscle what you see here on
the left are the controls where two
young mice paired together have one
muscle injured in one of the thighs and
it repairs at the normal rate I draw
your attention to all of those red cells
which so rapid repair the second thing
this control experiment shows is that
pairing a young mouse with an old mouse
does not diminish the young Mouse's
ability to repair its muscle so the
amount of new red cells is the same
another control is to compare two old
mice put them together and injure the
old mouse's muscle and here you see far
fewer red cells the repair rate is very
slow but the key result the one you can
guess is coming shown here at the end is
to pair a young mouse with an old mouse
and now injure the muscle in the old
mouse and sure enough look at all those
red cells the old mouse has now been
rejuvenated as it were it's repairing
its muscle at the young rate so we
dearly like to know what is
in Youngblood that stimulates muscle
stem cells in an old mouse to make it
repair better this raises the question
of what other aspects of Aging might be
affected by young factors might it have
to do with our loss of memory with our
heart function so we're very keen to
pursue these kinds of experiments
finding out what is it in a young animal
that stimulates old stem cells as it
were to make them young again
so you can imagine a time when you might
go to your doctor and she would say well
your liver is looking a little tired or
your muscle is not repairing well or
your bone isn't as strong as it could be
but don't worry we have some stem cells
that we've taken from you when you were
a bit younger we're gonna put those in
top you up and you're going to be good
as new I don't think anyone who's alive
today could live forever I don't see
immortality as a goal of this research
but it clearly is a theoretical outcome
I don't myself find that a very
interesting idea I wouldn't want to live
forever I've enjoyed all the phases of
life I don't think anyone presently
alive will live forever but I do think
this is the biology this is the science
that can lead to the possibility that we
could make animals immortal
so to summarize what I've talked about
today it's what I see is a new era of
Medicine based in regenerative biology
it starts from the fact the amazing fact
that all of the cells in your body has
this potential to make other kinds of
cells this has led to the discovery of
human embryonic stem cells and other
stem cells which we'd now like to use to
replace tissue and body parts and used
to understand the root causes of disease
I think you'll see soon that there will
also lead to the possibility of a
healthier life what I'd call healthy
aging where we're not trying to fix you
because you've had some disease or
injury but rather just replenish your
body to maintain its young and vibrant
state this will inevitably lead to
changing our bodies in a way that was
previously unimaginable
[Music]
I think in this time in our society
there are two interesting problems or
questions in science they both involve
the word renewable renewable energy is a
really important problem and there's a
lot of opportunity there
I've talked today about renewing our
bodies I find that I would say almost
impossibly interesting I can't imagine
anything more wondrous than how an
animal develops from a fertilized egg
and then how stem cells repair and
replenish that process there's an
excitement about scientific discovery
which is like practically nothing else
I've had in life when you discover
something about how nature works that
wasn't previously known that's
completely different than winning a
tennis match or making money on a stock
investment so people who like that kind
of challenge would find being a
biologist of fantastically rewarding and
enjoyable career thank you
[Music]
[Applause]